what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
I'm a little sick so pardon my voice but
we have a lot to talk about for Loki
season 2 we just watched episode 5 last
night and just like we've been doing
over the past couple of weeks we're
going to do a few videos breaking down
the episode in this video we'll break
down the ending of Loki season 2 episode
5 we'll talk about his time slipping
plus him Gathering the actual employees
of the TVA Mobius OB Hunter B15 Casey
Etc and talk about how it's always been
Loki's glor purpose to rule over the TVA
this is his Destiny it's what he was
destined to do in fact what's really
interesting is that today the official
account for Thor the Marvel Thor account
posted a video from the first Thor movie
of Odin walking hand inand with Thor and
Loki telling them that they are both
Born to Be Kings and the caption is
simply a clock emoji obviously
referencing Loki referencing the TVA and
time and of course Miss minutes so as we
go over the ending of episode 5 today
it'll also dive into what exactly is
going to happen in the finale in episode
6 also don't forget we started a new
monthly giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items all you have to
do is subscribe to the channel leave a
comment Down Below in our videos we pick
one random winner at the end of each
month and they pick one item so as we go
throughout episode 5 of season 2 of Loki
we realize that Loki is actually the
person who recruited these TVA members
at least that is what they are making it
out to seem like of course the question
is why doesn't any body remember this
when we're going through the events of
Loki season 1 or season 2 and that's
because it actually hadn't happened yet
it had but it also had not you have to
think about the very first episode of
Loki season 2 where Loki was back in
time with ob but Mobius was in present
time with OB OB did create a device but
not until Loki went back in time to help
him do it that made him create it in the
present time so basically it all
happened at one time the past and the
present and that is essentially what we
see happening in Loki episode 5 Loki is
recruiting his friends his family for
the TVA showing us that he was the
person who actually recruited them in
the first place they didn't remember
though because it hadn't happened yet
that's basically what they were prepping
us for with episode one and this is sort
of the OB the Ora borus the snake eating
its own tail the time Loop the chicken
or the egg kind of question they also
talked about this in episode 4 when
Mobius stated that if OB based his work
off of Victor timley and Victor timley
based his work off of OB then which came
first the answer is neither but it's
also both it's time travel it's
complicated that's how it is and again
that's what they have been prepping us
for this entire time now throughout the
entire episode 5 and really episode one
as well Loki is time slipping and it
appears that he has absolutely no
control over it however in episode 5
when he Time Slips he always goes to a
very important Place time slipping to a
very important person to him he goes to
Casey who is in Alcatraz who actually is
Frank from the movie Escape from
Alcatraz this movie movie was based off
of a real person named Frank and the
character's name was Frank as well and
this is who Casey is supposed to be in
this Branch timeline we even hear his
buddies who are breaking out with him
call him Frank so he Time Slips to Casey
Mobius Hunter B15 and OB and when he
meets OB he really finds out that there
has to be a reason for his time slipping
because it does seem to be very specific
he's not just ending up at random points
in time in random different universes
he's ending up in very specific places
visiting all of his friends so OB
determined that he needs to get all of
them together so they can pinpoint their
temporal Aura in different points in
time that way Loki can get back however
once he gathers everybody he realizes
that that's not actually what it is Loki
had been trying to control his time
slipping in this episode but he couldn't
until he realized that it's not about
what why or how but it's about who and
it's honestly an incredible story arc
for Loki he goes from this person that
we saw in the very first Thor movie who
is selfish and doesn't want anybody and
wants to rule over every everybody to a
person who now just wants to be with his
friends like he admits in this episode
so when he says it's about who he's
referring to his friends he's also
referring to himself he can time slip to
different points in time to his friends
or to himself a past version of himself
which is why he is finally able to
control the time slipping and go back to
right before Victor timley went out to
the time Loom and died and as many
people mentioned in our live watch party
this kind of makes Loki pretty op he's
essentially now a temp pad himself and
can control it so the god of Mischief
just got a lot more powerful and this is
where we go into what is going to happen
in episode 6 in the finale and how Loki
uses his time slipping to save everybody
we'll talk about that in just a bit but
first big thank you to fume for
sponsoring this
video fume is a GameChanger for a lot of
people in turning bad habits into good
habits a lot of people struggle with
these bad habits but fume looks at these
in a different way not everything in the
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit and that's
exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousand
thousands of success stories and that
could be you if you pick up a journey
pack today head over to trif nume.com
and use code Cosmic to save 10% off when
you get the journey pack today that's
trfu m.com and use code Cosmic to save
an additional 10% off your order today
so now that Loki has controlled his time
slipping he goes back to the point to
right before the TVA essentially gets
destroyed so what's going to happen in
episode 6 is Loki is going to tell them
what exactly happened they failed once
they failed he time slipped he met
everybody and he figured out how to
control his time slipping so now they
can essentially repeat this as many
times as they want they can fail over
and over and over again trying to figure
out what went wrong and how to fix it
and Loki can just simply keep going back
in time over and over and over again as
many times as it takes again it's the
Ora borus it's the snake eating its tail
it's the time Loop that Loki is now kind
of stuck in except this time it's
different because he's not exactly stuck
he can control it and is using it to his
advantage and that's how Loki is going
to save everybody in episode 6 so the
only question now is what happens after
Loki saves the TVA well you've heard me
theorize about this since episode 1 I
believe that Loki is going to take over
the TVA and essentially become he who
remains however he is not going to be an
exact replica of he who remains one he's
not a king variant but two he's not
going to sit in a citadel at the end of
time alone secluded erasing everybody's
memory from the TVA that is not what's
going to happen he's going to sit at the
head of the TVA with his friends helping
him run the TVA as well Loki admitted in
this episode he just wants to be with
his friends he doesn't want to be alone
that is why he is actually fit to rule
the TVA and essentially to rule the
Multiverse in a way so Loki will sit at
the head of the TVA Mobius will be by
his side with Hunter B15 OB Casey and
they will make sure people have free
will the time Loom will now be fitted to
be able to handle all of the different
timelines that way they can let them
Branch out they can let the Multiverse
exist and that way they can give
everybody their free will however as
I've been mentioning they will monitor
the timelines they'll monitor the
timelines for Rising Kang variants when
Kang variants get to strong or get to
technologically advanced Loki is going
to step in which is going to be the
exact premise of Deadpool 3 and Secret
Wars the TVA will step in with their own
team which I believe is going to be a
multiversal Avengers team a team of
superheroes collected from different
universes that Loki and the TVA will use
to ensure kangs don't get too powerful
and if they do they send that Avengers
team to defeat them that is exactly what
secret Wars is going to be so in a way
Loki is essentially becoming the savior
of the Multiverse and I truly believe
this is his glorious purpose to rule the
TVA and protect the Multiverse but let
us know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to not miss out on any
of our Loki videos coming up you you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter as well
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof